welcome to tonight's panel discussion
uh election 2020 what happened
and what's next i'm alan gerber i'm the
director of the institution for social
and policy studies
and professor of political science and
i'm going to be serving as
the moderator of tonight's event
isps is the sponsor of tonight's event
isps is a university research center
advancing disciplinary and
interdisciplinary research in the social
sciences
to understand our society and inform
scholarly debate
democratic deliberation and public
policy
the format for tonight's event will be
first comments from each of the
panelists they're going to talk for
five minutes or so following
their their initial comments we're going
to be having a panel discussion of maybe
15 or 20 minutes we'll see
see how much time we have for that and
then we want to leave a half an hour
for question and answer uh session from
the part
from answering questions from the
participants
let me describe some of the logistics of
that please send
questions uh throughout the
presentations
using the q a button on the bottom of
the zoom
screen tonight's event is being recorded
if you need technical assistance uh you
please email
isps yale.edu we're going to be
monitoring that
in case you have some technical
difficulties we can help you with
tonight's panelists uh i in order of
appearance i just want to
the way we're going to do this is i'm
going to introduce all all five of our
distinguished panelists and then
they're gonna just talk talk in order um
so in order of appearance
um tonight's outstanding panelists
uh first we'll be hearing from jacob
hacker uh
jacob is the stanley rezzer professor of
political science
and he was the director of isps from
2011 until 2020. so he was the director
right before right before me and which
was
so i have a lot a lot to learn from
jacob um
jacob is a member of the american
academy of arts and sciences
the national academy of social insurance
and the recipient of
numerous awards for his um for his
scholarship
he's especially known for his uh
writings on american politics and public
policy
and he is um he is an expert on health
care policy
and is one of the originators and
developers of the
the public option which is a really a
critical part of the
policy debate um on health care in the
united states
um he's the author of numerous books um
including
uh work with his co-author paul pearson
and i see right behind jacob's
uh right shoulder from his perspective
and i guess left shoulder from
ours is his most recent book let
them eat tweets um and so
so you can um that's uh you can help
make that book a bestseller
uh our second speaker tonight will be
christina
kanan professor kinnain is an assistant
professor of political science at yale
and a research fellow at the institution
for social and policy studies
professor canain studies the executive
branch
and political control of the bureaucracy
including the role of legislatures
executives
and the bureaucracy and policy making
professor kane is working on a book
manuscript entitled vacancy politics
presidential appointments and the
strategic evasion
of senate consent which investigates how
presidents strategically use vacancies
to promote their policy priorities
next we'll hear from isabella maris the
arnold wolfers professor
of political science marist studies a
range of topics in comparative politics
and political economy
including democratization clientelism
and corruption
taxation and fiscal capacity development
and social policy reforms in both
developed and developing countries
her recent book co-authored with lauren
young is
conditionality and coercion electoral
clientelism in eastern europe
and that book won the american political
science association's
extremely uh prominent and eminent award
the william reicher award for best book
in political economy
so we'll hear from isabella after
isabella we get
david mayu again we're going in
alphabetical order
david mayhew is sterling professor
emeritus of political science
a fellow of the american academy of arts
and sciences
the american philosophical society and
the national academy of sciences that's
the trifecta i think in in the social
sciences so congratulations to
david um david is a
renowned scholar of american politics
an expert on pretty much everything
uh he's a the author of perhaps the most
influential book
on congress of the last 50 years
congress the electoral
connection he has a lot of other books
every one of them is well worth reading
america's congress is a really nice one
two thousand
i i really like that one and then um
divided
we govern may or may not be the the book
to turn to
depending on how though in january
um and finally we'll be hearing from
saad omar
uh professor omer is a is a specialist
in infectious diseases
and vaccination policy in
2020 i don't know that there's any
post-election panel
that can uh can be formed without having
an expert on infectious diseases
uh like sod as part of the discussion
because of the
extraordinary importance of uh of our
public health policy
over the last year and in the coming
year
professor omer is a professor of
medicine at the yale school of medicine
and the susan dwight bliss professor of
epidemiology
at the yale school of public health he's
a fellow in the
fellow of the excuse me is the director
of the yale institute for global health
and a fellow of the infectious diseases
society of america
winner awards for his scholarship on
the impact of
he conducts research on interventions to
increase
immunization coverage and acceptance
again
incredibly critical public policy issue
in the coming months
professor omer served as an academic
affiliate
of the white house social and behavioral
sciences team under
i guess it was barack obama and he is on
the
advisory panels for the important
uh vaccination um trying to understand
uh what policies need to be set
regarding the
vaccination approvals and distribution
he's
on both the united states panel advisory
panel
uh for the vaccines as well as the who
panels so
so he is a um he is a uh a
real expert on this incredibly important
public policy issue
um welcome to all of all of our
panelists
um one last thing before we turn it over
to these distinguished panelists
uh in if you if you enjoyed today's
event
uh there's more uh we're having another
another event december the 1st at 7
30 7 30 to 8 45. tonight
uh tonight's panelists and our
discussion will be focused
to some extent a bit more on the
macro picture uh public policy
governance on the first of december we
have
a more of a political behavior heavy
panel
so if you want to know things about what
the voters did
and why did they do it you'll get some
of that tonight i would imagine but
you'll get a lot of it
on december 1st at 7 30. for that panel
we'll be having
alex copic and josh cala from the yale
political science department to
political behavior scholars
as well as mike podhorzer who is the
assistant to the president
of the afl-cio for strategic research
mike is a incredible expert on the
nitty-gritty
of america the american voter and
american political behavior especially
contemporary american political behavior
we'll also be having lynn vavrek
who has been conducting a tremendous
amount of survey research
during the campaign and she's an expert
on presidential elections and campaign
effects in presidential elections
so if you're interested in that angle
the political behavior angle
on december 1st at 7 30 please look out
for the isps
event what did voters do and why did
they do it
with that let me turn it over to to our
panelists who will speak without
any intermedia intervening interruption
in in their in alphabetical order
so please uh kick us off jacob
great thank you thanks so much alan
um thanks to lamar pierre and pam green
for doing the the back backside tech
um and preparation for this event and uh
thanks to this amazing group of
panelists um it's a
it's a real pleasure to be with you um i
also appreciate alan's
mentioning the book i see we have about
245 attendees so you could double my
book sales if you
you all went on and bought the book um
well i think we all should celebrate
it's now official um charles koch has
said that the winner
is joe biden so we should just like all
be clapping
um for those who didn't read the
interview with uh
with the elder coke brother um the
surviving of the two that
are associated with conservative
political causes um he also went on to
say that he was really sorry that he
messed up american politics
with all his investments uh to which uh
the twitter
twitterati um responded with uh
with a mix of humor and contempt um
here's my favorite
uh you he said you know something to
effective we really screwed things up
is what coat said this is the response
you can screw up a cookie recipe
you can screw up parallel parking those
things can be shrugged off and repaired
you can't screw up a country it's
elections it's media landscape
a major political party and just say
oops my bad
so i want to talk a little bit about um
that major political party because
i think we should first recognize that
the electoral defeat of a would-be
authoritarian
is a very big deal i i think joe biden
would add a
another word to the to the description
between big and deal but this is a major
accomplishment
um but i think as as paul and i to argue
paul pearson and i argued in our book
let them eat tweets which begins with
the line
this is not a book about donald trump
donald trump is not the sole reason
um as uh charles koch's comments suggest
that our democracy has not been
working as well as it could or should um
and i think the election delivered a
kind of split
verdict um on the future of american
democracy on the one hand
as i said um would be authoritarians are
rarely defeated at the polls
and democratic backsliding as the
comparative let's call it could have
continued
much more quickly had donald trump been
re-elected
but at the same time the fact that
republicans
actually gain seats in the house may
well hold on to the senate
it seems like the more likely outcome
i'm sure david will give us
examples of every uh off every
uh runoff race in the history of the
united states to
analyze the prospects but it seems
likely that republicans
will hold the senate and thus that mitch
mcconnell will be the majority leader
um and so that and that um is obviously
going to mean
that um the president elects
ability to achieve many of the goals he
set out during the campaign will be
limited it also means and i think this
is
really important um to understand is
that the
the pressures on the republican party
change course are going to be less than
they might have been otherwise
um back in in the in the late
uh well actually the early 2010s uh
barack obama famously asked whether the
gop
fever will break um and that fever
unfortunately still seems to be raging
um the um the the other thing i want to
just
mention and i think we should talk about
tonight is the extent to which
this um this party that has been
radicalized over the last generation
um has managed to in ins insulate itself
from electoral accountability in many
ways
um the fact is that republicans have
burrowed into america's
counter-majoritarian institutions
uh they hold it their appointees hold a
decisive
uh majority on the supreme court and
lower courts uh it's a notable fact
that uh the 6-3 majority on the supreme
court is
a good chunk of the people who
constitute it were
either or both appointed by a president
who
did not win the popular vote or
confirmed by a senate majority that did
not represent a majority of americans
and we know that the senate is heavily
tilted
uh towards rural america and that rural
america is heavily tilted toward the
republican party
and we also know that the electoral
college has become
uh a much advantageous terrain for the
republicans so there's a variety of
reasons why republicans
are under less pressure to moderate um
even though the most extreme
instantiation
of the republican retreat from uh
from the center donald trump was
defeated
so i'll just close in my last few
minutes by mentioning
um you know what i consider to be the
kind of
a half full or half empty uh version of
our democratic glass right now
so on the one hand as i said i think
we've seen a clear rebuke
uh to a president who um in
has continued to flout democratic norms
and who as i said represented a clear
and present danger to american democracy
um
on on the other hand the fact that we
have republican silence or worse
in the face of a failed president deal
continuing to de-legitimate our
elections
is an extremely worrisome sign that
we're going to see
continuing intense fights over the
future of american democracy and
american politics
the base of the republican party is
thoroughly trumpian
the structures of organized outrage that
have supported him
remain in place uh indeed fox news now
looks like a moderate alternative to
other
sources of information for conservatives
and finally
we know from history that obstruction
has paid off for the republican party
mitch mcconnell once again will uh be in
the position
of deciding what is possible for an
incoming
a democratic administration and will
almost certainly say as he did
back under president obama that his top
priority is to make
the democratic incumbent a one-term
president how will it end up
let's stay tuned and let's discuss it
tonight
okay well thank you jacob and thank you
uh
alan and pam and more for all of uh your
organization efforts i am thrilled to be
here
to be a part of this um uh incredibly
amazing
uh panel uh and uh to kind of
you know discuss and and digest a bit
of what we've experienced politically uh
for the last
year of the election uh for the last
four years of this current
administration to kind of look forward
um the the topic of this panel being
uh you know this what happened and
what's next
uh jacob you you let us off with such a
wonderful
set of thoughts on how
we might consider uh moving forward with
the republican party as it is
i'd like to add a little bit of my own
uh flavor to that mix and and
and think through or at least you know
start the conversation
when one of the pillars of the biden
campaign really ran on which was
the administration's handling or
some might say mishandling of the of the
covid19 epidemic and
and what that really shines a bright
light on is
uh the way in which the administration
has handled
uh appointments to uh the federal
bureaucracy
and the way that the administration has
ran
and managed our government uh or or
mismanaged as as somewhat
some might say um and particularly
thinking through exactly what happened
in the in the last four years the trump
administration is leaving us with
with a federal government that is led by
mostly acting officials and these
oftentimes are
or not oftentimes rather almost entirely
not vetted by the senate they're not
confirmed by the senate they're
selling those positions on a on an in
trump capacity
but under the federal vacancies reform
act they're only supposed to serve for a
limited amount of time and trump has ex
has exceedingly um either just blown
past those deadlines
or submitted nominees to a senate who
as as jacob so nicely um put
is run by republicans and you would
think would then confirm his appointees
but aren't
they aren't confirming his appointees uh
this leaves these actings uh
in those positions we've seen a variety
of things come down where those actings
are potentially not
uh uh legal they're potent they're the
decisions that they make are not legal
most recently with acting secretary of
homeland security chad wolfe
and what this the question this brings
is what the biden administration can do
in the process of transitioning
when you transition to a new
administration you're reliant on the
individuals who are feeling the
positions
at this time and oftentimes uh
in that transition you'll see the top
cabinet positions
set off and the deputy secretaries take
over for a short amount of time
to kind of fill the gaps as an acting
but when you have
acting deputy secretaries or you have
vacancies in those acting deputy
secretary positions so that the
uh someone can move up into the acting
secretary position itself
this this calls into question exactly
how the biden administration is going to
get their feet under them and get off
onto a good start in in and and really
when our conversation turns to what's
next that's what we have to start
thinking about with the binding
administration um
transitioning out of this election and
thinking about the hurdles that already
exist to a new administration
you have 1200 uh presidential
appointments that require senate
confirmation to be
filled now we can have a conversation at
a later time as to whether or not that
is necessary the politicization of the
federal government
certainly uh is is questionable for
a lot and has been a subject of of
research for political scientists
but but when we when we think as to what
biden's going to be able to achieve as
jacob mentioned
um he's going to need to rely on those
appointees and if if he is stymied um by
the senate in terms of confirmation
trump has really laid out there uh
almost a playbook for pursuing his own
uh strategies of appointments um
outside of the senate so i'm i'm excited
to kind of think through uh what that
means as well
with the rest of the rest of the
panelists thank you
okay thank you so much to ellen for
inviting me to be part of this panel and
to um pam and lee moore for organizing
so as alan mentioned um i am studying
comparative politics
uh and so this identity in fact helps me
today
because quite honestly there's so much
about the 2020 elections that i don't
understand
okay so so at the time allen has asked
me to be part of this roundtable i
wouldn't have anticipated that we would
be today nearly two weeks after the
election in this ambiguous situation
which is a slow motion
so the outgoing president has not yet
recognized the legitimacy of the
election nor has he yet considered
defeat
while perhaps this is unsurprising for
donald trump
what is more worrying about democratic
erosion is that the republican party
is complicit with the strategy nearly
half of the political class
elected to the senate and to the house
today are complicit in a strategy to
delegitimize
a democratically elected president
yesterday the washington post
reported based on interviews of the
georgia secretary of state
that senator lindsey graham tried to
pressure him that the georgia secretary
of state to find ways to exclude legal
ballots
so how does this moment in time how does
this unprecedented democratic fragility
of the united states
fit in the democratic landscape of
eroding democracies
so i want to draw attention to the fact
that if we look
in a comparative setting the situation
in the united states is bleak
so hearing about this episode yesterday
i want i was reminded about nancy
bermeo's a very important book
ordinary people in extraordinary times i
don't know how many of you here are
familiar with the study but to my
knowledge this
is the best account of democratic
erosion we have in comparative politics
this is a study of 18 countries that
experienced democratic breakdown in
europe and latin america
during the intro period in the 60s and
70s
burmell asks the simple question what
distinguishes cases that remain
democracies
from cases where democracy ultimately
collapsed
her main result is highly relevant for
the situation of the united states today
the study zooms in on the importance of
elite behavior
and on a variable that vermeo calls
distastic capacity
she defines distancing capacity as the
ability of members of the incumbent
party
to distance themselves from the behavior
of their from the
lawless behavior of their co-partisan
allies
and i ended the quote so evidence of
such distancing capacity comes in the
form of condemnation of lawlessness or
the prosecution
this was present in finland and the
czech republic in the interwar period
and this was where these members of the
dominant elite sanctioned
violence or transgressions of democratic
norms but was absent in countries that
sort of right where democracy collapsed
so what is remarkable about the united
states today
in broadcast comparison to these
historical cases
is that it takes extremely low measures
on the variable measuring distancing
capacity
moreover i cannot see a way how this
distancing capacity can be established
within the republican party
who the actors of change are and what
sanctions they may have at their
disposal
to enforce this behavior among their
co-partisans
so at this critical historical juncture
republicans are complicit with trump's
decision to deny the legitimacy of
election
just to increase their bargaining power
with a new president
so this in my view creates a very somber
scenario for the bible presidency
who will have to devote considerable
energy to fight off
accusation of the legitimacy in the eyes
of sort of about
30 percent of the voters so the future
in my view is weak
okay so time after the elections
i have sort of one or two kind of you
know thoughts about the outcome of the
election
and they have to do with the nature of
populist appeals
the elections have yielded very
ambiguous results that i find
quite difficult to understand so even
though president trump lost the election
over 70 million voters voted for him
this comes in the middle of an
unprecedented pandemic and the
disastrous response of the federal
government
to this public health crisis so this is
really puzzling for most explanations in
political science that highlight the
ability of voters to sanction
bad politicians especially in moments of
economic crisis
okay at the same time the election has
yielded very ambiguous results for
democrats
even if president baiden won the popular
vote the election has not been
successful by most democratic candidates
down ballot
the democratic majority in the house has
shrunk and no democrat competing in red
states has been reelected
so what explanations do we have in
political science to make sense of these
results
this suggests to me that we have really
not fully appreciated the power and
strength of populist appeals
so what do i mean by populism so even
though we have experienced four years of
a populist president
it's quite hard to explain what they do
they govern through provocation
they govern through the creation of
enemy the fake media the quote unquote
rapist migrants the quote-unquote
chinese virus
what populists do is that they're
introducing the policy discourse
a new dimension that is orthogonal to
the existing policy dimension
and so they govern by flaming up this
rhetoric of opposition of elites and so
this is what we call in political
science
thin populist anti-elitist sort of
strategies
so we don't have a good explanation of
how these messages work and we outright
dismiss them as being kind of the
theatrics of a populist but i think we
don't fully understand how this populist
rhetoric was successful
to maintain the electoral coalition of
trump in the face of the dramatic
economic shock
of the pandemic so let me again turning
to the pandemic right how did
trump respond to the pandemic like other
populists around the world
he had two strategies anti-scientists
deny
the existence of the virus and sort of
the anti-foreign strategies blaming
foreign countries such as
china on the virus so to understand
certain right how these messages
surround have helped him uh maintain
support
among sort of right this is 70 million
voters which i mentioned above
it's important to think about to write
the two effects of survived populism
one is that this orthogonal dimension of
political competition creates a really
difficult choice
for other parties whether or not to
engage with this issue
should the democrat have responded to
all this nonsense about
the chinese origin of the virus but i do
think the more important consequence of
these messages is that they have
spillover effects
on the main axis of political
competition the left right dimension
so in other words what populist messages
do is that they depress
the support for policy or the demand for
policy
even among groups that are very severely
hurt
such as voters who have experienced
covet or have experienced downturn
and we have sell lots of survived survey
evidence that i have collected with
colleagues here during the pandemic
sort of documenting this that callings
or rights are
if you expose to voters to these
messages of the virus is a hoax that in
fact depresses their demand
okay for for policy of voters that have
experienced an income
shock so i do think this is sort of
right part of the
explanation of this puzzle why trump was
able to maintain his
electoral coalition intact during a
pandemic
without providing any policy response
and by engaging in thin populist
messages only
this is what barry wandas has called us
for the tragic brilliance of the
populist
and i think kind of this this sort of
thin populism explains another sort of
right puzzling outcome of the election
which is the growing educational and
geographic polarization of the
electorate
so voters without college education have
to be appeared to have resonated most
strongly to these
anti-elitist messages and sort of right
and by
tapping into this anti-elite resentment
these messages have undermined
the support of these voters for a
distributive policy such as college
credit or medicare for all
all advocated by the candidates so i
will add
these comments i'm suggesting that so
right we as political scientists have a
sort of a deeper obligation
to really understand so write the
importance of these messages
um in in creating this uh this very
paradoxical result that we have seen in
this election
got it okay well thanks for inviting me
uh ellen like i want to say
very very quickly what happened and
what's next
which was what we're supposed to do what
happened
i think the election is a considerable
victory for moderation
and probably for coalition government
over the american sword
i think the fever is down that is with
trump dispatched
and the left pretty much staved off the
fever is down
that is the menace that each side sees
in the other side
is substantially diminished on both on
both sides
the democrats gained the presidency and
the vice presidency by a considerable
property of majority
as it happens and one in that one senate
seat
republicans gained something like 10
house seats
and one governorship and two state
legislative chambers
and conservatives had some notable
victories in the referendum process
processes
in a lot of ways it's a standoff though
of course the presidency is a big prize
and now bite he gets it
with a substantial popular edge
i think the coalitions this year voter
coalitions are basically a continuation
of ones that we've seen for
20 years or so in an evolution of them
we've been evolving
into a a kind of class cleavage between
diploma people that is a college diploma
people
and non-diploma people it is a
cleavage that would have surprised marx
but there it is
you'd have to rewrite the whole business
but it's a it looks like a class
cleavage
it's a cleavage of interests that are
preferences
and of attitudes that i don't think
political science studies particularly
well
i think the election was nicely
conducted it's a great success
there's a lot of a lot of reviews that
are saying his preview is saying it's
going to be a terrible mess
and even though some votes came in late
we knew that was going to happen it's
ordinary processes
a little extraordinary this year because
of covet but fight
defensible and i think properly handled
processes
this seems to be no fraud and a little
disorder
just footnotes and disorder here and
there that can be ignored
uh trouble isn't trump's denial is not
going anywhere
it seems to be a kind of closing tantrum
that he's engaged again that may go on
for another week or so
it's so it won't go anywhere it doesn't
have anything to do with the
with the uh who holds the office it's um
the complaints will go on that the
election was unfair
this is somewhat different matter of uh
difference of weather can be overturned
on the on the evidence unfair
but we've seen that before in fact we
saw it after the 2016 election it's
unfair there was russia and all that
it's a page out of andrew jackson
remember him with the uh
charging for four years with corrupt
bargain of course it didn't affect it
with john quincy adams at the white
house during those four years
we're not getting resistance in the
streets last time as
the way we did last year after the 2016
election
all in all as i say i think the fever is
down as the victory for moderation
i think maybe the democracy is dying
script
should be put back in the final cabinet
the what happened now the what next i
think one main
effect event going on into governing
is that there'll be more day to day and
week to week stability in the white
house
that is not a minor thing there's firing
people expostulation
changes erraticness that's going to go
away
it's a good thing it goes away
particularly probably for the conduct of
foreign policy
i think that in governing biden gov
president biden president-elect biden
can do a great deal with executive
directives
and we'll see that in the fashion of
obama and
trump it's kind of a ping-pong
category character to that one president
does thank you the next president takes
it back and the next president may do it
again but it's important and some of it
sticks
so we'll see executive orders of some
importance and that this
presidential committee got to do
something in a hurry as trump did early
on and that will be
the sort of that would be what biden
does in a hurry climate change
we'll go back to the paris comparison
court sooner or later
the pipeline hanging down from canada
won't be built the business regulations
will be taken away there'll be no
immigration and so forth but there are
there'll be a lot of ruling by
zusean dictats from the white house and
the bureaucracy that'll be there
but there are limits to executive orders
that are not executive orders they're
not executive directors more generally
are not embedded in statutes and so they
they um they're perishable as trump's
as we'll find out some of the trumps are
and the courts are out there
the courts are are probably good they've
got to kind of bulk up in their policing
of bureaucratic dictats given the
doctrines that are in the heads of some
of those new justices so so there we are
it's um it's um there we are now i think
on capitol hill
we're going to have narrow majorities
whatever else happens in era majority in
the senate
a nun there a majority in the house it
looks like
formal divided party control which is
after all normal
in american politics seventy percent of
the times the states eat eighty
it's the normal way of governing we
can't be sure it'll be formally divided
party
because we now know about georgia
georgia down there
we've got those two republican seats
hanging
and there it is it's i don't know what's
going to happen i'm not holding my
breath for the
democrats to take both of those seats
it's difficult the uh
the track credit somebody mentioned i
would talk about the track record of um
of runawas in georgia has been pretty
favorable for the republicans and i see
that dumping an
awful lot of money and publishing who
knows we just don't know a lot of it'll
depend on what happens during the next
eight weeks after all
elections started some degree reaction
so what happened we got six weeks before
those elections are before that election
is held in georgia
another thing you'll have on capitol
hill well with divided departing control
is dependent on
on the georgia seats but there's joel
mentioned there anyway
even if the democrats pick up those
those two georgia citizens then probably
joe manchin
the conservative democrat from west
virginia becomes the pivotal senator on
some matter
so he's already going on saying it's
taking some positions that the party
doesn't like
uh also on capitol hill it is the
democrats in the house are having
trouble uh arraying themselves and
picking elite enemy
i think nancy pelosi is going to get
restored as speaker though she's going
to have to fight for it
for every last person
every every dice person there are the
majorities in arrow
both sides so the democrats in the house
looked like something like 223 to 212
something like that it's
narrow it's a in georgia
yeah yeah so we'll just we'll just see
what i already said that it looks like
it was after that stage before
confection so
that is this fierce scrapping some of it
is come out into the press during the
last week or two
between the progressive faction of the
moderate faction and so on
which makes it very hard to run that
party but i want to say this i mean
nancy pelosi there's a tendency to blame
the leadership
in congress if the if there is
because they can't hurt the cats
sometimes some of that but
we should realize that factions within
parties on capitol hill are very common
in american history indeed
possibly normal but sometimes they're
not so easy to see
as with the tea party faction which then
didn't show up in the role called voting
because the party leaders could at least
arrange what has been voted on in the
floor
to minimize their apparent to minimize
their real factionalism so
it's a tough job that nancy pelosi has
got but we should realize that we
shouldn't blame her or blame the
democratic party
if they're killing each other it's it's
it's and some of them believe me i think
some of those people like to kill each
other right now among those democrats
the way they're talking we'll see
but factual factions in congress are an
extrusion from the society
at a normal extrusion from the society
so let's not blame the party or the
leaders
on the capitol hill it's uh the
democrats ambitious legislative program
is not going to happen
almost certainly not going to happen
during the next couple of years or
probably in the next four years given
the numbers
it's certain there's a list of things
that probably won't happen we won't have
a
police reform the way the democrats
would like it
there'll be no agreed to a deal there'll
be no ban on fracking
be no medicare for all will be no public
option it looks like there'll be no 15
minimum wage we know bannon right to
work laws
there'll be no contract unionization
they have a long platform you know some
of this is platform and some is just
the sort of stuff the parties wanted to
do for some time when they get a chance
so we know election reform
there'll be no big tax hikes there'll be
no car packing that's not
gonna go and then i've got to get rid of
the filibuster or even tamper with the
filibuster i thought two or three weeks
ago that the democrats are going to have
enough
big enough majority in the senate to to
to cook the filibuster at least cook a
lot of the life out of it but that's
that's not going to happen right now joe
manchin says no they can't touch it
all this is not going to happen if joe
manchin the democrat does become the
pivotal member that some of this alters
today joe manchin
apparently is open to some tax some tax
take back some tax coalition making
which might the party the democrats
might be able to put through
through reconciliation in a 50 senate
that includes patching woodville
that's there but on this other stuff
it's not clear that some
the man-to-mansion question would make
it make a difference
be aware though that that um
ashes to ashes that is a personnel
personnel change there's some important
change some important changes
the coalitions of the congress hacking
because people die and retire as with
teddy kennedy back in tragically in 20
2010
you remember that and in the past uh
people defecting or people dying or
people retiring people going to the
cabinet have affected
the coalition control on capitol hill
close to it so we can't
anyway there's no there's no crystal
ball that can take us into that one
but i would say finally that without
this program without an
ambitious legislative program i i don't
i don't have this
i think with biden's presidency there's
not so much space
for hot and betten for
four four four four is my picture up
there it's at the top right
david no you're absolutely your picture
is is perfect
um you're coming up to about about 10
minutes so
and you'll have an opportunity to um
amplify amplifying some of these themes
during the
question and answer and panel discussion
is there a final thought you'd like to
leave us with
before we move it's got a tough
presidency it's going to be a an inbox
and management presidency like harry
truman's not a legislative program
president she's a very tough four years
coming up
terrific thank you thank you saad omer
so hi um you must be might be wondering
what a
an epidemiologist is doing here and
there's one explanation
um since uh everyone went home
on march 15th um there's a
an oversupply of armchair
epidemiologists so you know maybe i'm
taking
revenge uh you know on
other fields by becoming uh an armchair
political scientist
um in this um you know in this
post-election season now
that's not the reason um the reason i'm
i'm here
is because uh this pandemic
response in the u.s has been a failure
there is no other way to describe it
those of us who
have been working on infectious diseases
including
pandemic preparedness my first
interaction and my first serious effort
was actually around 2006
when h5n1 influenza was a
was a risk um and so and so forth and
was engaged with some work around
h1n1 and a lot of people
had expected that there could be a virus
which would impact the us
in the way it is impacting us now which
would
lead to deaths even more deaths or could
lead to deaths
in higher numbers but no serious scholar
um had imagined uh and have asked around
i have asked people
that if we were we always thought if we
were this bad
in terms of mortality and mobility not
necessarily spread but specifically
mortality there will be
a hundred other countries worse than us
um and
there was a for example that the latest
global health security index
um ranked which was came out
in 2019 ranked the us as number one
um and obviously we are not number one
at least not in a positive sense and the
reason why i'm here is that it's not a
failure of science
we have had pcr and antigen tests and
social distancing and masks
and vaccines although these are newer
types of vaccines
but the overall vaccine approach for
decades
what failed wasn't science what failed
was governance
and and in public health if uh
i want to prepare for the next pandemic
i can't
do that without um an approach that
involves
a serious mature hard-nosed look at
governance
and governance you know you know it is
sad i know you know i'm sure a lot of
you are aware that um
democracies don't have famines um you
know
i'm paraphrasing
someone obviously but democracies have
pandemics and
democracies make a mess uh it seems
of uh pandemic response so so that's the
reason
why we need to discuss this why that's
why
institutions are important that's why
appointments are important that's why
prominence of career folks and political
appointees
in decisions and random radiologists
from stanford
is is important and so
one of the things going forward would be
important is trust in institutions
and and part of my work is focused on
vaccine acceptance and trust in vaccines
and a lot of it a lot of people that you
have seen
uh different servers we when we looked
at it it was in may
we found only 67 would uh
sort of right away except the vaccine
the rates for through other surveys peo
and others
have actually gone down of outright
acceptance and these are not your
run-of-the-mill
um anti-vaccine folks there's a huge
chunk of folks
who are who says who were suspicious of
the process
who saw what happened with uh
hydroxychloroquine
who saw what happened with convalescent
plasma where there was perhaps a reason
uh to um issue emergency authorization
and you could argue
have a good faith argument about the
merits or demerits of that
but the way it was projected the way it
was politicized freaked a lot of people
out
and since then there has been a course
correction at the fda
through due to pushback of the career
folks uh but also
um due to
um push back of the political appointees
at the fda as well
but the general public doesn't know and
so therefore
we need to the fact that i'm seeing um
this huge gap in the response um
in terms of serious investment in
vaccine confidence
and serious investments in a national
education and communication campaign
public health has you know this is not
the first time
there has been a public health response
but whenever we have had
a major national or international level
response we've had an evidence-based
um education and communications campaign
it's an and a communications campaign is
not run through
press conferences or or tweets uh
exclusively social media is obviously a
part of all of this stuff
but it has to be coherent and it has to
be
reasonably evidence-based
and so i'll share a piece of data that
we generated in collaboration with alan
and greg huber and a really talented
postdoc from political science scott
beaucamper
where we had these survey experiments
where we found that even if you
had approval of the vaccine a week
before the election
versus in december there would be a much
higher acceptance
and confidence in vaccine uh if it were
approved in december and that we did
this
survey experiment way before the
election several weeks before the
election
um and so so that is reassuring we also
found that elite endorsement by
uh dr fauci by tony fauci but also
bipartisan
endorsement could move people so that
kind of evidence is there
in the context of vaccines uh i have
looked at the impact of liberty and
purity value so
extending some work borrowing some work
from jonathan hyatt
and looking at it in the context of
vaccine decisions whether there are
moral decisions or not
turns out a lot of these decisions are
moral decisions um
and uh some of these and i've been
looking at specifically at liberty and
purity for a while
and because of uh these authoritarian
strains
that have come to that have become more
prominent in in other fields as well
in terms of pushing back against other
public health interventions
we are seeing uh you know some of that
work is
newly relevant uh in this particular
context
so i will wrap up by saying that you
know moving forward there are a lot of
things
that concern us public health types
governance is at the top of it but also
um based on the composition of the
courts um one of the things that makes
me nervous is that the foundation
of a lot of public health law is this
decision that was done around
smallpox mandatory vaccination jacobson
versus massachusetts
um and that um has and that
sort of in a way explicated the police
powers
of the state um in the modern era or
relatively modern area that decision was
of the progressive era
at the turn of the 20th century
and that decision has spawned a lot of
thinking
a lot of mainstream both legislation and
regulation with the new composition of
the code
uh i'm not sure uh that we can take
those kinds of interventions for granted
uh etc um and so
you know part of my work has been on the
using
behaviorally designed legislation as a
public health intervention
and so there are certain things that we
took for granted i don't think we can
take it for granted
so i'll i'll stop here and i'm sure
we'll have the opportunity to discuss
several things
um and and just to reassure everyone
this is not a revenge
i'm just great crashing because you're a
fun lot
all right thank you thank you very much
side um and thank you to all the
panelists
so um we have a lot of questions coming
in from the audience i just wanted to
remind everyone
that um when we conclude the panel
discussion in about 10 minutes or so
looking at the clock
i'll start with some of the questions
that are being sent in
uh to the question and answer function
and
they're some of the questions are are
the questions i've been trying to read
them while also paying attention
to my colleagues and the questions are
are
outstanding and some of them are kind of
long so
it's i'm doing my best to sort of
remember like like balance all this so
good good luck to me
um for now let me just start with just a
couple questions and then we'll go to
question and answer
so my first question um to the panel
is um there's a difference of opinion on
the panel maybe
people noticed uh that there was a
little bit of a difference of opinion
regarding
how concerning uh the post-election
period
ought to be i think if i remember
correctly isabella i believe called it a
slow-motion coup d'etat and i believe
david uh referred to it as
um the menace has diminished and where
we're now kind of getting back to
to normal we've gotten rid of trump on
the one hand
and that's what the the you know the
democrats and
we're concerned about and we the
election was not a resounding blue wave
which um which was what the republicans
were worried about
so we're kind of uh the temperature has
gone down
and we're um we're now entering a
a period of uh of a
more calm um and more normality or
i guess i don't i i don't have his exact
words um
so isabella and david and anyone else
who wants to
um wants to enter into the conversation
here
david why um why aren't you more worried
uh and uh and isabella um
uh could you then respond to what david
has to say about why he's not more
worried by the things that are clearly
worrying you
and if anyone else wants to jump in of
course uh feel
feel free to do so once isabella and
david have had a had a moment to
exchange their views on this i debate
okay
okay i thought look i think that in
order to contest in the
election successfully you need to have
some cause to do it some empirical cause
to do it like the very close vote in
florida
in 2000 and then that difficulty carried
all the way to the courts but it was a
600 vote
or something like that difficulty they
had to see what went on and they had to
look see and fight about what went on
nothing like that is happening this year
they're just telling stories
trump people are just telling stories
that's about it
yeah so i um i agree with professor
mayhew that
uh clearly this um this election
um you know um when surprisingly well
even that was what was anticipated um
and there was no post electoral violence
the survive very little fraud very
literally irregularities so all this
industry of you know worry about a
democratic erosion sort of right
has in a way been been proven wrong
um my comments referred more to the
uh i i linked this sort of right uh
period more to the survive to the intra
in a way elite conflict
that is happening sort of now um and so
right so in a way where i come in or
where sort of right my worry comes in is
more having survival i mean again
thinking about
the effort to delegitimize of course i
mean president biden is going to be
um you know be our next president
uh okay but still right i mean if you
look at the surveys today
30 percent or more of voters still right
believe
that uh that uh you know this is not a
legitimate president
okay so uh because kind of right i mean
these whole strategies that um that have
been so rather that trump has used
during the campaign about sort of
invoking fraud have resonated with some
voters
so the concern here is more about um
you know uh shrugging off this um
this um uh you know illegitimacy kind of
image in a way um and sort of again and
if we look at sort of right i mean the
book by my name in super mario that i
mentioned also about everything we know
and compared to politics i mean i and i
don't like to use this comparison viola
germany but
in glamour germany the problem was that
sort of write a significant part of the
population
never thought that democracy was
legitimate and that sort of right
it was never possible for the democratic
kind of group
um in uh society at a time to sort of
shrug off that
uh that sort of red image so this is a
very risky
uh you know strategy one sort of write
this uh this is on the agenda and once
you're right you fight about this
and uh you know answer right based on
what we know this uh sometimes
you know sort of right it's it's just
not possible and it doesn't end well
okay so so i think we are commenting on
different uh on the different
parts of the uh on of the sort of right
of the election and um
and already these things are very very
hard to seize the red what's going to
happen sort of right looking
forward um okay instead of right i mean
kind of you know um
um with with this right with these
release voters so that's
so i think this is where the
disagreement is
david do you have a response would you
like just to give a response to that and
then if anyone else wants to come
just a little bit it says it's
unsettling when you get a fair
proportion or don't think an election
was legitimate it's unsettling it
has happened rarely in american history
it happened last time
you probably get more than 30 percent
after last time most of the election
outcome was not legitimate but we've
gone past it
i hope now that the fever going down
that uh
all this will go away i don't think our
uh comparisons with my job
with my wife my martinez collapse make
any sense at all the economy had gone
down to zero in 1931
the parliament had a majority of parties
who were
anti-democratic at what they professed
there's nothing like those things going
on in the u.s today
okay i have a feeling this could go back
and forth for some time so i'm gonna
i'm gonna move on to another question or
another another commenter if there is
one if not we'll
move to another question seeing no
comment
let me ask saad a question uh
a kovic question you mentioned
i think the sad facts of the us's
uh performance metrics that they're very
they're very poor
um on the on the on covid so
um we have two more months until um
it looks like i guess that according to
this panel uh joe biden will be the
president
um so let's just stipulate that's the
case um so joe biden's gonna be the new
president
but what can joe biden do now i mean are
we waiting two months well
if you were joe biden assad um what
would you do
tomorrow uh uh to um to address the
pandemic
well uh so thank god i'm not joe biden
but um
in terms of um the
what can be done what should be done um
both on the domestic front and on the on
the global front
um because there is an opportunity that
will be lost
uh if we don't we're not at the table um
for you know in the next two three
months and i'll come to that in a second
but domestically uh we need to have a
and
i can go on and on for the whole
response but i'll focus on vaccines
for now first of all
the idea is to have a national
communication and education campaign
that's one thing which is based which
has three
goals one that it should be at scale
so one thing in public health which i
call pilotitis is
we keep on doing successful pilots uh
and not
you know it's almost a disease that you
know we don't scale up
to to national level impact so so
avoid the temptation of uh you know
doing things here and there be ready for
a national level campaign
um at scale
it should focus on trust it should
also engage communities and the first
and the last one is not
at odds there are ways to engage
communities at scale if you have a
template
community organization is done at scale
for all sorts of things
and voter mobilization is one example uh
but it's not the only example
so these should be the goals and it
should be science-based we should be
ready for
uh now they should get ready now
for for that kind of a campaign but they
should decide on the fate of operation
warp speed
uh from now and send it back to the
agencies perhaps
um or have a more um
sort of career folks involvement by the
way it's already has
a pretty substantial career involvement
and even the outside person
who co-leads this is uh you know it's
fairly mainstream
and and actually if there is a um a
counter factual
to uh things not being handled by jared
it's operation wap speed other than the
name it has produced it is
bringing together the agencies public
health agencies and other government
agencies nih barda fda
cdc around an umbrella have a
coordination
by people who know what they are talking
about um
and look it has been yes the the naming
could have been different
um etc they could have paid more
attention to communication but in terms
of developing a vaccine it's been
it's been a reasonable success but but
they need to decide on that
what happens afterwards how did they
mount
a national response not just a federal
response
so engagement of the way it can happen
is
engage non-governmental professional
associations
for now um like the
association of state and territory
territorial health officers
that's out there there's nothing
stopping a campaign
from engaging with them directly the
association of immunization managers is
out there
um engagement of companies
the infectious disease society of
america the american medical association
all of that don't you don't have to run
the shadow government
for two months but you can get ready for
these kinds of things
uh when uh you know for for january
great thanks a lot son um and then i
i'd like to ask christina and jacob um
so david laid out um a a a scenario
where very little
uh of the of what you might call the
progressive agenda
um becomes the law uh in biden
administration
um christina um you're an expert on
appointments the bureaucracy
um can you tell us um how that might
work um
under divided government or especially
if the
the republicans remain in control of the
senate
and then um after jacob if you could say
a word about whether you concur
with david regarding i guess it's hr one
and all of its
um political reforms as well as all the
legislative reforms
do you concur with david regarding what
what is likely to
transpire in terms of the democrats on
political reform
and legislative agenda so christina and
then jacob
and then um after that i think we'll
open it up to questions from
our audience so i'm going to be going
afterward
right to the q a function thank you
well great yeah so um the first of all
i think you know david recognizing that
uh the likelihood of legislation being
stymied in congress is pretty high
particularly given uh you know the small
margins and so
really it's gonna it's gonna it's gonna
be administrative policymaking that's
going to be
the way forward and even in a situation
where you have a senate
uh say georgia doesn't end up
turning both of its special elections
towards the democrats but instead the
republicans hold them
there are the vacancy the federal
vacancies reform act
allows for a considerable amount of time
after inauguration
for acting appointees to serve and we've
already seen that the public
really doesn't have a huge issue
with the major management of
the federal government being individuals
who don't have senate confirmation if
they had had that
with it peppered across the news you you
would imagine there being some type of
pushback against trump and and there
just hasn't been
uh uh from from his republican base or
really from from much of the democratic
base outside of the the really
controversial ones like
chad wolf and like the newest shuffle at
at the department of defense
but the federal the fcra allows uh
for 300 days for an it for an acting
uh in a appointee to serve
after inauguration and then an
additional 210 days
if a senate uh nominee is submitted and
not confirmed and then another 210 days
after that
so if you're keeping track at home
that's nearly 720 days
of interim appointees and that almost
gets us to midterms
so there are a lot there's going to be a
lot of places
uh for administrative policymaking to be
led
by the biden administration it just
won't be led by the biden administration
with the senate's consent which that in
and of itself we can have a whole
another conversation about
so very quickly i mean first of all
david david was my dissertation advisor
and i think there
there is a there's like a you know if
there's the
reagan's rule was thou shalt not
criticize a fellow republican
uh thou shall not criticize their
dissertation advisors pretty high up
there
um but but i'll say that i i haven't put
my concerns about democratic backsliding
into my file cabinet i think it's
very much front and center still and i
was and i
my greatest regret about the election
honestly is that
you know uh there there there looks to
be very limited scope to pursue some
sensible democratic political reforms
small d
democratic political reforms and to me
the the um
everyone knows what the big ones should
be it's not court packing
it's not puerto rico and dc statehood
though i
would be supportive of the of the latter
um
it's making sure that every american has
the right to vote
and that politicians uh are prevented or
at least have reduced capacity to choose
their voters rather than
um than voters choosing them through
extreme partisan gerrymandering
um the prospects for those things are
dismal but i think one thing that
democrats should recognize is that
fighting
fighting the good fight is sometimes
good politics too i would
push for these and i think that's why
senate control is crucial it's joe
manchin's
gonna prevent i mean my public option
does not look to have the greatest
prospects uh in joe manchin
senate but if the agenda is hell is
controlled by democrats because they
have the senate majority
um then there will be the prospect for
bringing these things
uh before the congress before the
american people and having that debate
which i think we should have on broader
policy changes
i mean assad is right i mean we're
we're living in an alternative reality
show where a significant chunk of the
political class
is pretending that um that what's
happening
uh that what donald trump believes is
happening is uh
or at least are not pushing back against
his belief about what's happening
and in the real world people are dying
um and they're dying because
we're not having we're not having an
effect we haven't had an effective
policy and we're not going to have an
effect
effective policy we're going to have a
failure of
we're not going to be able to formulate
an effective policy if we can't have a
transition that moves forward smoothly
or
if we don't have any capacity for
uh for for the incoming president to
cover now
i'm hopeful that at least on the really
fundamental things that seem that need
to happen
then uh that that will happen but i i
thought shod
put it really well that you know we have
seen some
some pockets of confidence and operation
warp speed
um i agree on the name i think we can
call the rest of the
the uh the covid policies operation
death star maybe
um but anyway um let me just end by
saying that um
that uh that that i that i think that
the
the the biggest silver lining in this
and was mentioned in the q a
is that we are going to turn the corner
and we're more likely to do so
faster if we have some effective
leadership and
so there this may not be a typical
midterm right
um it's a not going to feature a lot of
polarizing legislation
and it's b going to feature a big
significant reversal in our situation
which may well
uh make it more likely that um
that that the the president-elect will
be in a better position
um than he might be otherwise um in a
few years
so um thank you very much jacob okay so
i'm gonna go
some of the question and answer um some
of the
questions have been answered uh during
the
comments on on the panel um other other
result
less so um i'm going to try and kind of
weave my way through the questions
so um here's a question um i guess i'll
direct this first at david and then at
the
anyone else who wants to wants to
participate
um question is do you think there'll be
any legislative common ground
between president joe biden and a
republican congress so this is in the
event that
that um you know though that the uh
republicans get one of the two georgia
seats um
you mentioned all the things that
weren't going to happen can you say a
bit about
um what you think might might happen and
then of course anyone else who wants to
comment
i would be welcome well for one thing
there always has to be common ground
ultimately on budgeting
budgeting has to take place every year
and budgeting is commonly
a consequence of things
both parties tuck into a large
instrument so that
you get common ground in that sense
that's very important a lot of policy
making is done in the budgets
another thing is that i think biden as
everybody says
biden is very good with dealing with
people on capitol hill and probably i'm
not sure about this with the
mcconnell that is that it's i mean
they're good there are better vibrations
there than we've seen of sunny is
between the senate leader and the
president probably anyway
i think there are some there are some
policy areas
in which there might be some fruitful uh
cooperation between them i mean
infrastructure is one everybody talks
about infrastructure but nobody's got a
plan and
certainly know they've got a plan to pay
for it
but it is an area in which non-partisan
activity can happen
so if they put their heads to it it's
possible they can do something on that
front
but um any i i can't actually
see as well because i've got this
question and answer screen that i
that's sitting in front of of some of
the panelists
i don't see anyone else wanting to
comment on this so we'll move on to the
next question
so the next question is is one about the
the
kind of the generally political
coalitions
um the the questioner asks
about exit poll data regarding
independent voters i'll just read the
question and i
i'll i'll ask you to comment on the more
this issue and as well as its
implications more generally but here's
the question
i've seen exit poll data that
independent voters generally perceive
democrats to care more about
social issues and republicans to care
more about economic issues in 2020
and the conventional wisdom is that
voters tend to prioritize economic
issues over social foreign policy issues
at the ballot box i've also seen some
high-profile left-leaning pundits
believe this explains
democrats sliding among
non-college-educated
latinos in 2020 is this exit poll data
considered high quality
if so is this something the democratic
party should aim to correct
so um if anyone wants to address that
particular aspect
of the political coalitions that would
be great
um if you would like to also address
more generally
the question of what might we we don't i
don't know that we do have really
reliable exit poll
data for a variety of reasons but we do
have some
begin we're beginning to see what data
from
precincts um and from um from counties
and
and house districts and things like that
that that does seem to indicate um
uh some uh some shifts in the republican
voting coalition
uh would anybody like to comment on on
this question
and also informed by by other data about
how
the republican voting coalition um
might have changed uh over this um over
the
last several years and as evidenced in
this election
hey well yeah excuse me okay
exactly yeah fire away you see some of
this on the map but when you go to south
texas and south florida you can see
on the map right the democrats did worse
than they expected and usually have done
among hispanic voters that is to say
that most hispanic voters don't still
vote democratic they do
but nonetheless at the end you see it on
the map it's not just exit polls
right um any any comments about
the so we're going to actually have a
whole a whole panel
on this sort of voting behavior these
voting behavior questions
in two weeks and we have um uh
some amazing people who are you know
experts on that
nitty-gritty of um of these sorts of
questions
um that doesn't mean that others don't
have opinions that they might want to
share and
about looking at the panel um i want to
as a i am not an election expert and
isabella did you want to jump in
i see your mute is off no okay so i'm
not an election expert i'm
really looking forward to that panel i i
i would just say three quick things one
is
given how far the polls were off in
general
um and we'll surely have a discussion of
that at the next panel
um i would be i would be careful about
exit polls right now
second um it it's not going to come to
it's not it's it's not going to be the
case
that we're going to have seen a
fundamental shift in the bases of these
parties right we're talking about
enormous continuity and indeed
i mean i really do think that the
central fact of american politics today
that we saw is
both sides were able to get lots of
people out but
the persuasion was operating on a very
small segment of the electorate right
and the degree to which there is a chunk
of
that this is something isabella noted in
comparative the degree to which
despite an enormous catastrophe
electoral alignment seem fairly stable
is is itself a very remarkable feature
and the third thing i would say
is that you know wherever it came from
joe biden put together a pretty
effective map
and it looks especially remarkable when
you compare it with
the rest of the democratic um
electoral candidates the rest of the
candidates right
that that's that's and that's why he's
going to be the next president right
right
good okay thank you very much um another
question
um uh self-deprec it has a
self-deprecating
part this might seem a terribly
uninformed question
okay it's actually i think a good
question um
and isabella you might have something to
add to this um
uh and others i think as well but why do
we need to have this transition system
when other countries
have the newly elected head of state
taking office the very next day
um what's up with that uh this
transitions this this
two and a half whatever a month
transition system
it is a little strange isn't it um
isabella could you just put this in
comparative perspective and then
david anyone else who wants to comment
that would be great
i'm looking for maybe professor mayhew
knows form not being an expert on
american politics it seems to me this
isn't this a legacy of the
electoral college and the fact that
right you had these institutions where
they had to gather together
and sort of come so it's just this
historical accident i think kind of that
is connected to the electoral college
that's sort of right that creates this
you know this kind of lag that we
you're yes so so um i think isabelle is
frozen not me
is isabella frozen okay it's usually me
i'm sure christina or david can tell the
basement state david you want to jump in
and then isabella can catch up or
christina
and this sort of right then well when
you know what has happened to these
efforts
historically because probably we're not
uh at the only moment in history when we
are
kind of agonizing about you know having
to wait for uh two months um
the great depression well that was that
was a big one with two for roosevelt
but david do you have a comment you'd
like to make well that's a good question
and
i don't maybe we don't need long
transitions
it's easy to see why it's there then why
it should be there because it's a
hangover from the 18th century
originally they had a longer transition
it was from
early november to early march and then
they collapsed it a bit
but the collapse two months a delay is
a residue i don't know maybe there's no
good reason for it maybe it has
something to do with presidencies but i
don't know the
presidency's general i just don't know
christina
is there something you'd like to add
yeah i think also a lot of it in
parliamentary systems you have shadow
governments you have minority
governments that have their own shadow
ministers that are
involved in the process of
administrating the government whereas
in our system we don't have that we
don't have
a democratic or republic opposite party
secretary of state or an opposite party
uh
secretary of transportation and so the
transitions
actually starts well before the election
the transition starts
is is is weakly mandated to start six
months before the election and that's
when
the uh the the individuals who are
currently
in the administration uh they they get
together they find their leaders within
each department
who will lead the transition and they
create documents they create
transition landing manuals in order to
inform
the new administration not only of
the status quo of policies and
regulations that are
still in play are still being processed
but also just
who people are and where the positions
are there's a
the um plum book as a as it's called is
is a you know 600 page documents
uh book that's published every four
years giving way
to the all of the appointments that need
to be made by a new administration
and because of the way that we've set up
our our federal
appointment system the new
administration has to come in and fill
all those spots and so not only
figure out what spots there are and who
is filling them but then also
where what kind of world those people
are leaving and whether or not they even
want those people to leave
oftentimes we have a lot of holdovers
that
that hang on after the transition
because
um because it takes so much time to get
your feet under you
and it looks like one of those holdovers
this year will be donald j trump
so it's actually an interesting thing i
i guess um because it's not a party
system the
how would the shadow you know the shadow
cabinet work
with because it's this shadow cabinets
associated with a political party
we don't know who the nominee is until
the the summer
they would have to then put together the
shadow you know the shadow cabinet
i would imagine unless that's something
the voters expect and demand
people have all sorts of reasons not to
want to
have to put forth the shadow cabinet uh
if unless they were compelled to
by by by uh public pressure because the
folks are then
vulnerable to all of the you know this
was i remember i worked on a political
campaign where people uh were suggesting
the presidential candidate
named 10 people who might be the
possible vice presidential
nominees and we were petrified that it
would both be
ridiculous and also open each of those
people up to
a withering attack um if they were if
they were named they would
have a have a target put on their back
um if they
once their name was names were released
okay
let's uh get a few more questions in i'm
going to go to the
bottom here and let's see what we've got
let's see
um
okay here's here okay here's a question
uh professor canain are there cabinet
seats that are critical
to fill quickly so while i'm looking at
the other questions
what are the cabinet seats that need to
be filled right away
all of them all of them okay
do you care to elaborate certainly um
i typically you know secretary
first of all there's there's you know
the line of succession is of course uh
important to to recognize uh uh in
you know and oftentimes uh cabinet
positions are confirmed
kind of in order of of where they sit in
the succession line
uh being secretary of state first um but
we face
we we face as as assad has said we face
a world
of just epic proportions of mortality
and morbidity that needs to be addressed
immediately so
really you need a you need you need a
department of homeland security and you
need a department of health and human
services
like on day minus two right like you
need someone
who is facilitating and coordinating
this this
massive scale intervention that needs to
happen
um not only uh for vaccinations but also
for the fact that you have an entire
disinformation campaign to overcome
you need to you need to inform people
that their hospitals
are at max capacity and what that means
for them the fact that
just because you aren't experiencing or
don't believe that covid
is is a thing that happens or a thing
that will affect you
doesn't mean you won't at one point
potentially need to be in a hospital
like we should all stop driving our cars
if there's no icu beds in case we get in
a car accident we should
we should watch out for all of the
individuals who have heart conditions
that
won't go to that won't seek health care
because either they can't
because hospitals are full or because
they are afraid of
the risk of catching covet and so you
have that you have
as sad so nicely put you have this need
for an administration that is not only
working but
is on the ground and and so
interior is important it's always going
to be important it might be less
important in terms of
dealing with the the the situation at
hand
thank you very much christina okay so in
our in our final
few moments together i i just want to
ask the group
um maybe in in order of appearance uh
uh on the panel um what are
where do you go um personally uh
uh for information um in this in this
uh uh in this time of of great um
great great national upheaval and
political change um what where do you
seek out information
and what have you read recently uh
a book or an article or two um that has
informed the way you think about
politics that you would recommend to
interested members of of our audience
here um
uh what would be a really interesting
thing to read like i think isabella
mentioned
nancy bermeo's work and and it's it's um
that's you know deep scholarship that's
also of
of relevance so so what might you
recommend to our
to our community um so we'll just start
with jacob and go in order of appearance
um yeah so um i would recommend
probably spending less time on twitter
and um
and more time talking to people um but
uh what i found i found you know
it's going to be predictable but i found
it really helpful to have
um the very regular updates that
the times is providing as well as the
long-form journalism that's been
appearing in the
in the atlantic i think has been
excellent during this crisis
um i would speaking of another
long-form journalist i would read jane
mayer's wonderful piece about mitch
mcconnell that appeared
um earlier this year we'll see how
relevant it's going to be
and um books that have really influenced
me i've actually told a number of people
this and that
i'm not sucking up to my uh senior
colleagues um
jim scott's against a grain which is
really a remarkable book
it's a lot of it's about the way
pandemics have reshaped society
so i recommend it highly great thank you
jacob
um i forget who is second was it
christine
christine you know yeah um i agree with
you
jacob uh about staying off on twitter
although i do have to say
and and i think that that you know um as
as
not certainly one of the armchair uh
epidemiologists that saw i've railed
against
i definitely feel that getting into epi
twitter
uh made me epically more aware of the
oncoming
uh uh pandemic uh it back in in
february and march than then probably it
would have been elsewhere so
so i must say that there is an
incredible information campaign that is
happening
by epidemiologists uh to their absolute
credit on twitter
um there's a lot of work um that that
has been done
um uh to to accumulate data and to
accumulate knowledge
in really readable forms so i i mean i
agree with you that twitter is
it's by and large bad uh for for
for making for your blood pressure i
think but um
but but for uh for information that you
might not uh
uh easily come in contact with i think
you know getting into one of those
circles is great
um in terms of books um will howell
and uh terry mo's uh newest uh book on
the presidency um
i found uh fascinating and infuriating
at the same time
um mostly because it's about populist
presidencies and
and i think i would recommend that 100
um so
great thank you christina um isabella
yes
so um i thank you for this question it's
actually very thought provoking and so
for me
um i have been reading a lot of
historical books on pandemics
uh just trying to understand and one
that um
i strongly recommend is um uh by um
you know a historian at ucla his name is
peter baldwin and the book is called
contagion and the state and it is about
sort of you know historical responses to
health crises
uh so i would add that to the list
officer
also nancy bermeo who is an author that
i find sort of highly relevant
today i mentioned at the beginning thank
you very much isabella
david i'll go to jacob's room do you
mention jim scott's book not agree with
that one but a book something like that
which i recommended to you by the way
is by walter scheidel is an economic
economic history professor at stanford i
can't remember the exact title but i
think it has
equality in it or inequality and also
has
violence in it it's about equality and
inequality during the last 3000 years
great thank you david and assad
so i would recommend and i've been
reading a bit uh not as much as i would
have liked to
because of some of the other stuff that
i've had to do
but i would say very earlier on
early on i went back to uh camus um
the plague um it's it's a classic um
and and you know and it's it
you know i'm not exaggerating you know
it almost gave me goosebumps
in terms of you know earlier on like how
um the more things change the more they
remain the same
etc so i would suggest going back to
that
the atlantic has had some of the best
writing on the pandemic i absolutely
agree especially ed
young's um work on it it's very
thoughtful
it's not uh at all superficial
um and the last thing i would say if you
care about institutions
read the long form article by propublica
on
cdc's uh role on this take the time
um read it and then read it again um
because
there are lessons for other institutions
as well
so you know i'll pause here thank you
very much um
thank you all so much for taking the
time
to um to join together this evening
for this conversation um i hope everyone
in the audience appreciated as much as i
did
i'd like to once again uh advertise
we're going to do this again in a
slightly different way
in two weeks we're having a session what
did voters do and why did they do it
another panel
discussion sponsored by isps um with
that i'd like to
again thank the panelists thank pam
green
and the more pier who work to set up
today's event
and thank you all for joining us i look
forward to seeing you
at future isps events thank you alan
thank you bye bye everyone bye